Dù là un ph hop, thấy như tuyệt vọng này
Thế bắt đến đây
đánh tor hết
Chào các bạn bởi vì con con chào
Trời tr MICH Nó
Wifey bị đánh giết bởi vì một phí vào
vô tên lửa tên
Đói ngтаки tên chứ?
Inmediate a chứ?
Tôi có thể tên lầy như vô tên
Vô tên lửa em, và tên lầy như Signature
Tế củaw
behöça các em nhìn này.
Chắc có nhiều viceculін này.
Thस nhìn h equip xác etwas đóo boux cửa...
và đặc opposite là anh thấy có thể những đánh đỡ.
Đúi bình đ SmackT青 r comun.
Bắc ông người yêu, vẫn còn là bánh đỡ là đánh đỡ.
Trong trong bằng b assumes đã ngheb các nơi như đánh đỡ.
Nói ngheb.
Mày đủ, nhưng đó không?
Cầm hoạc lần này.
Chúng ta sẽ không ngheb.
Nói đánh đỡ là ăn.
Bây giờ, anh có biết được những đánh đỡ là phải là đánh đỡ ra.
Bây giờ, tôi sẽ không có thể đánh bảo vệ.
Chúng ta sẽ không có thể đánh bảo vệ.